Our subject this morning and next time
is the age pandemic and all start this
morning dealing in a sense by popular
demand because I know from visiting
sections that people were particularly
concerned with bringing the study up
today and talking about
where we are at the moment.
So I'll be concentrating largely on the
global pandemic and where we are today.
Then next time we'll look
more conventionally, uh,
the history of the aids epidemic focusing
on this country and the experience or
the United States is how
I'm proposing to do it. Uh,
we'll start with the uh,
sort of run through if things
that you probably know very well,
but that we really ought to
discuss a bit as background,
the nature of the disease,
it's course in the body and its symptoms.
And then we'll move on to the epidemiology
of where the pandemic is today and
some of both the worrying aspects about
this pandemic and also a couple of the,
uh, rays of hope, that of
progress that has been made,
especially in the last couple of years.
So that's where we're headed this morning.
First of all,
in terms of the disease,
um,
you know already because
we've talked about viruses,
in this case,
a retrovirus.
And here we have a slide,
a schematic picture of the HIV virus,
you know, um, about it.
That is so core containing two
strands of genetic material,
RNA in case to,
in a membrane with two glyco
proteins on the surface.
The glyco protein,
particularly this one, one 20,
is crucial for allowing the
virus to target certain cells.
In the case of this virus,
it targets the t four cells in the body,
which are the ones that
regulate antibodies and are
the regulators of the body's
immune system.
Well,
once attached to the t four cell,
the RNA penetrates the host cell and
for a time it's inactive even for years
there then occurs a trigger or detonator,
which may be this is a little speculative
and infection that activates the t
four cells.
And then the RNA is converted into DNA
that penetrates the chromosomes of the
host cell and turns it into a factory
for the reproduction of the virus and the
killing of the cell.
So the retrovirus is
an absolute power site.
It takes over the controls of living t
cells and turns them into factories to
reproduce virus.
Now this we can see also and a picture.
This is a slide of an
infected t cell and this is
okay.
An image of a cell reproducing HIV.
And finally,
let me show you.
Okay,
this is a picture of an HIV particle
budding from an infected t cell.
So this is how the part of the mechanism
of the disease and let's talk about
what happens to the body
in terms of symptoms.
First,
there's an incubation period of some six
to eight weeks after which you occur.
There occurs.
The primary infection symptoms at that
stage in the majority of cases are flu
like that is to say fever,
night sweats,
muscular aches and pains,
fatigue, swollen lymph nodes,
headache, sore throat, sometimes diarrhea,
sometimes around cash.
Then the symptoms disappear after a
few weeks and in many cases there's a
prolonged period that's
entirely asymptomatic.
This is a period of latency which can
last months and has been known to last
even as long as 10 years or more.
The time being entirely unpredictable,
but during this period the virus continues
to multiply and destroy the cells of
the immune system.
Then there comes the period of active
aids when their direct lesions caused by
the retrovirus carried in
some sell cases to the brain.
Sometimes there's neurological damage
known as age dementia or loss of motor
control memory,
sometimes reasoning power,
but the characteristic as you know of age,
different from most infections is not,
it's not the symptoms that it
causes itself,
but rather its ability to give rise to
opportunistic infections by switching off
the body's immune system,
making it vulnerable to an exotic variety
of infections that the body is unable
to fight.
This is immunosuppression.
Later in the disease,
the victim experiences weight loss,
lethargy,
recurrent yeast infections,
rashers are sowers,
fevers and night sweats.
Active aids develops when a patient
has fewer with HIV than 200 t cells per
microliter of blood.
The normal count is 800 to
1200 so from this point,
the average untreated and
I stress untreated age.
Patient has about two
or three years to live.
Sometimes other symptoms develop
difficulty in swallowing,
loss of memory, cough,
shortness of breath,
sometimes seizure,
nausea or impaired vision.
But death is usually caused by a whole
array of opportunistic infections with
names familiar to you like candidiasis,
pneumocystis carinii pneumonia,
Kaposi's sarcoma,
cytomegalovirus,
cryptococcal meningitis,
but above all tuberculosis,
which is the most important of
the opportunistic infections
of aids and globally
at least the most common
immediate cause of death.
So note this characteristic of aids,
it's course is not just a direct
result of the virus itself on the body,
but those pathologies which are substratum
are combined with those of a series
of other diseases super imposed on the
aids virus because of the progressive
destruction of the immune system.
And note how well adopted the virus is
to its ecological niche and the human
population.
It's a lethal disease,
but one that avoids killing
its hosts too quickly.
A major evolutionary advantage
begins with the lengthy,
a symptomatic latent period
as HIV when it's contagious,
but the infected patient almost certainly
doesn't know that he or she harbors
the virus in his or her body
and then full blown aids can
last for long years while again,
the patient remains infective.
Well. What about transmission?
Transmission can occur
in a variety of ways.
As you know,
it's transmitted sexually.
Everyone knows that we need to remember
there was a myth about aids and the
outset in this country in the
80s that it was a gay plague,
that it spread homosexually and you
all know about the moral majority and
Reverend Jerry Falwell who welcomed
Aids is God's sword to destroy
homosexuality.
Apart from blast for me and the arrogance
of the claim to know God's will,
what's most striking about fall was
comment is his complete ignorance of the
facts of the epidemiology.
The virus is present in
bodily fluids, blood, semen,
vaginal secretions,
breast milk.
So one means is certainly
sexual intercourse,
especially intercourse involving and
infected partner where there are lesions
that allow the virus to penetrate
the skin and enter the bloodstream.
Hence sex,
heterosexual or homosexual where there's
a preexisting venereal infections such
as herpes,
it's particularly dangerous or sex
that causes abrasions such as anal
intercourse.
So the risk factor is not homosexuality
but promiscuity by which I would define
as sex outside the context
of a loving relationship,
whether heterosexual or
homosexual and Africa.
Today it has been established epidemiology
logically that multiple partner sex
behaviors account for two thirds of
all new infections but age can be
transmitted in other ways
despite what Jerry Falwell said.
It can be transmitted through the
blood by shared needles and syringes.
For example,
needles that haven't been sterilized but
our shared one thinks of injecting drug
users.
One can think also have patients in
resource poor health systems in which
needles are scarce and
not routinely sterilized.
One can think also of
unsafe blood supplies,
blood that isn't screened
and it's supplied to people
by people who were in are
remunerated.
Their buying,
making every transfusion a risk for
HIV transmission for patients who have
surgery or for homeopathy,
hemophilia acts.
Another factor of course is
the sex industry where the
disease spreads rampantly
among sex workers and their clients.
And then there's vertical transmission.
A real shock to Jerry Falwell.
The disease can be transmitted
transplacentally from
mother to fetus or from
mother to infant via breast milk.
This is one of the drivers
of the present day pandemic.
In 2008 the latest statistics children
constituted just under 20% of all new
infections and nearly the same
percentage of age related mortality.
Well, what about the
epidemiology of this pandemic?
We're now a quarter of a century
and to the global AIDS epidemic,
and I would argue that age is a good
example of one of the themes with which we
began our course.
Whether epidemic diseases are part
of the big picture of history.
And I would argue that you wouldn't be
able in the future to write the history
of the late 20th and 20th first centuries
without devoting an ample space to the
AIDS pandemic.
And it's consequences
from the standpoint of the
industrial world, western Europe,
North America.
Some people have a comforting illusion
that the emergency's been controlled for
a couple of reasons.
One is the fact that the number of cases
in the developed world has leveled off
except that in the last few years there've
been some troubling signs including
right here in the United
States and secondly,
there's been the development of expensive
drug cocktails that have reduced
mortality significantly with many patients
experiencing the disease as a chronic
illness, but we need to be
very careful about complacency
and there are only seven countries in
the world that have more cases of HIV
infection than the United States.
In 2006 there were 1.2 million people
living with HIV in the United States and
the number is not declining at all.
Furthermore,
we need to remember that living with
HIV as a chronic disease is itself
enormously problematic.
It means an expensive and complicated
regimen of pills and the medication itself
is toxic and has unpleasant side effects.
The evidence seems to suggest too that
patients with HIV AIDS undertreatment
experience,
nevertheless a significantly higher
incidence of other diseases and that they
die at a significantly lower age.
And then very disturbingly since
2004 there's been a real spike in HIV
infections among men
who have sex with men.
Meanwhile,
worldwide,
the pandemic continues and the words
of the UN aids report for 2008 it was
continuing at a staggering level.
At the end of 2007 the World Health
Organization reported globally,
the 33 million people
were affected by HIV aids,
that there were 4.5 million new infections
during that year and during that
dreadful year,
nearly 3 million aids deaths.
That's something like 8,200 people a day.
2006 also witnessed 4.3 million new
infections in 2007 and eight the number of
deaths decreased and that was partly
due to the increased access to therapy,
antiretroviral therapy that lowered
mortality in 2010 for the first time.
UNH suggested some reasons for optimism,
but optimism of a strictly limited kind,
not that progress was being made to
controlling and decreasing the epidemic,
but that it seemed to have leveled off.
That was one of the hopeful stories
of the UN report of this year.
It remains true though that most people
in resource poor countries who need
retroviral therapy still don't receive it.
But let's look at some of the graphs of
this was HIV at the end of 2005 and it
shows the total of 40.3
million people with HIV aids.
And below that it shows the numbers of
newly infected people and the number of
AIDS deaths for 2005.
Yeah.
And this gives you some idea of the
dramatic inequality of the burden of HIV
aids.
That it's enormously
a burden in sub Saharan Africa,
which has more than half of
the total number of aids,
uh, people in the world. Or
let's look at this picture,
which just gives a clear indication
of where the epicenter of the AIDS is,
which is in southern Africa,
countries such as Botswana,
Lesotho, Swaziland,
Namibia, South Africa, Sim,
Bob Way and Gola Mozambique there the w
h o reported in 2006 and again in 2008
that the epidemic was still rampant,
that the trend still offers no comfort
and in the sub region as a whole,
life expectancy has actually declined
because of aids to below 50 plunging to
levels not seen indeed since the 1950s
Swazi lend in Botswana have the unhappy
distinction of having the world's
highest prevalence of the Aids Hiv aids.
And here you see the worst case scenario.
26% of people are infected with HIV,
the highest levels ever recorded
as our 20% of pregnant women.
Those are rates of prevalence that the
center for disease control once thought
to be impossible and life expectancy at
birth dropped below 40 years and several
countries in the region with nearly 6
million people living with HIV in 2008
South Africa has the sad record of
processing the largest HIV epidemic in the
world in absolute numbers,
not the per capita now epidemia logically,
it now seems that there are two great
dis virgin patterns in this terrible
epidemic
in the industrial world.
It's primarily an affliction
of high risk groups.
We'll talk about them in a moment.
Men who have sex with men,
sex workers,
injecting drug users
out.
This is what the World Health Organization
calls concentrated epidemics in which
the pandemic is confined above
overwhelmingly to
certain high risk groups,
but there's a second and
more devastating pattern,
clearly evident in southern Africa.
We're HIV AIDS is a leading cause of
death and we're transmission among high
risk groups certainly occurs,
but it's overwhelmed by transmission
and the general population.
Their transmission is primarily through
heterosexual sex and significantly more
women are infected than men and
it's also true as I've said,
the transmission occurs on a large scale
vertically from mother to unborn child
so that significant numbers of
children are born with congenital aids.
Now,
why women,
and this is again a none of the themes
of our course and while be dealing in
part here with poverty and not just
poverty but in a quality women in part
because of biology,
the disease is more easily transmitted
from men to women then vice versa.
It's also true,
clearly true and sub Saharan Africa that
sexual activity tends to start earlier
for women,
young women in many parts of sub Saharan
Africa also frequently have sex with
much older partners.
Sexual inequality also fuels the sex
industry as does the epidemic is our prime
also by violence against women and
often the inability of women in many
situations to negotiate safe sex
practices and many parts of the world.
Girls are simply severely discriminated
against in terms of education and
therefore did not acquire sex education
and knowledge necessary to take
effective measures to protect themselves
and control their reproduction.
Girls who have not received primary
school education are twice as likely to be
infected with HIV as those with higher
educational attainments and as I said,
violence against women is a
major factor in the epidemic.
It's also true that we need to mention
cultural norms in these areas where
notions of masculinity are
important determinants of
male behavior patterns that
increase the risk of aids,
the idea that it's meritorious to have
multiple partners and unmanly to use
condoms well.
This is an epidemic that can serve also
as a review for some of the themes of
our course.
We see this epidemic being primed by
a number of factors that by now we're
familiar to you and comparative discourse.
There's a clear link with poverty.
The countries with uncontrolled epidemics
are among the poorest nations in the
world and poverty is directly
linked with the epidemiology of HIV.
AIDS.
Poverty prevents national governments
from building effective public health
structures or educational infrastructures
and studies of sectors most at risk
from the epidemic in southern Africa that
is sexually active young people in the
15 to 25 age group.
Those studies reveal that large numbers
of people of that age group still do not
have an accurate understanding of
the mechanisms of aids transmission.
Local studies also showing some places
that disturbingly large numbers of
sexually active young people,
25% have been discovered in places,
still have no idea of what a condom is.
Poverty prevents people from having
access to means to defend themselves.
Education,
medical care and treatment
for those already infected.
It drives recruitment
into the sex industry.
Another major driver of the pandemic,
it leads to unemployment,
demoralization and alien nation,
all of which fuel high risk behavior
including intravenous drug use,
and that in turn leads to
further unsafe sex practices.
Then there's the social and economic
impact which is maximized by the age
profile of the victims themselves.
That is young men and women in the prime
of life who should be the main stays of
families and their economies
and some places.
Poverty even destroys the effects of
sex education itself and Uganda for
example,
the newspaper,
the Uganda Monitor reported two years
ago that condoms remained so far beyond
the means of many people that a widespread
practice was to boil them after use
and reuse them.
Then another theme in our course,
we've talked about urbanization
and its role with certain diseases.
Not all malaria was
clearly very different,
but it's no coincidence that southern
Africa where the pandemic is rampant is
also rapidly,
rapidly urbanizing and that indeed 20%
of the global burden of HIV AIDS falls on
15 cities in southern Africa.
Another theme of our course is represented
by age and that's the impact of glow
of conflict and war.
The movement of troops once again
has proved to be ideal for sexually
transmitted diseases and for prostitution
and the spread of other STDs,
syphilis,
gonorrhea and herpes actually
furthers the spread of aids.
The lesions that they cause like genital
ulcers provide ideal portals for entry
of HIV into the body.
Trade and modern means of
transport have been important.
One can't understand the
AIDS epidemic without roads,
railroads,
the airplane.
Societal neglect is a theme we've talked
about and national governments in some
cases,
nations that are poor and underdeveloped
and have virtual status as almost
failed.
States have been incapable of taking
major initiatives on their own in terms of
improving the health of other
pop that their populations,
but in some cases they
also have other priorities.
There's the siren song
of military spending.
There's corruption or let's take the
case of the former president of South
Africa Amiki who refuse to take science
seriously and rejected the idea that the
HIV virus causes AIDS.
He calls on people not to use condoms,
but simply to drink a mixture of olive
oil and garlic as a prophylactic of
choice.
So there's been a current of
aids dissidents who relink
reject the link between
the virus and the disease.
Fortunately that situation has changed.
Then there's stigmatization which is
a cause of the spread of the epidemic.
It causes people at risk not to seek
medical attention and that in turn
undermines surveillance and active
understanding of the epidemiology of the
disease and the inequality of women
who are stigmatized has a number of
structural consequences.
That is in terms of inheritance laws that
dis and franchise them unequal jobs in
the economy,
violence,
early sexual debut and large spread
practices of what Unh cause calls
transactional sex in Kenya for example,
teenage girls are three times more likely
to be infected with HIV than boys of
the same age and the differential
instead of decreasing increases with age.
There is also the displacement
of people and aids.
Hiv Aids thrives on migrant labor,
on disrupted families,
on refugee status were and in
industries where migrants live,
for example,
among minors in compounds at vast
distances from their homes and families.
A situation that leads to convert
the thriving of commercial sex.
Mobile populations are at
high risk of infection.
And then one of the vicious factors of
HIV AIDS is the burden of the disease
itself,
which causes the burden of poverty
to increase and poverty furthers the
epidemic.
So age then leads to a vicious downward
spiral in which Fokker d creates
favorable conditions for aids,
aids breeds poverty and so on.
In the words of the UN aids report
for 2008 HIV causes a greater loss of
productivity than any other disease
and is likely to push an additional 6
million households into poverty by 2015
HIV has inflicted the single greatest
reversal and human development
and modern history.
That was the UN report and then there
is super infection that is multiple
infections with different strains of aids.
And one of the most tragic factors of
all is the phenomenon of AIDS orphans.
The who reports staggering
numbers of them.
It turns it a crisis of Gargantuan
proportions already in Subsaharan Africa,
11 million children under 15 are orphans,
a number that's expected given current
and projected prevalence of HIV infection
to reach the staggering figure
of 25 million in a few years
and worst affected cases.
It could be if this actually materializes
that one child and five could be an
aids orphan.
Well,
what are the effects of this
dreadful pandemic on societies?
Again,
we see the functions almost as a
review of themes of our course.
Clearly you will,
no one would be able to write the history
of the present moment and southern
Africa without giving a
central place to HIV aids.
HIV AIDS prevents education and
literacy at the heart of the epidemic in
Botswana is the fact that the disease
kills teachers more rapidly than they can
be replaced.
That poor families with a member ill from
aids can't afford to send children to
school.
The fact that it destroys healthcare
systems and many countries in southern
Africa,
50% of all hospitalizations are due to
HIV AIDS and nearly all other healthcare
interventions and programs have therefore
been erased or radically downscale.
It destroys productivity and creates
a crippling burden of disease,
destroys families and communities,
thereby trapping whole countries and
under development and international
dependency.
It destroys civil society
and undermines democracy.
It's a substratum for a lethal
epidemic that follows in its wake,
the reemergence of tuberculosis,
the classic opportunistic
infection complicating HIV
AIDS and TB is rising at a
rate of 6% per annum and southern
Africa where 2 million cases of TB or
diagnosed year businesses find that
they're crippled their high rates of
absenteeism.
There's a real shortage of
skilled workers available.
There are high rates of turnover and
it's extremely expensive to train new
workers and of course the rocketing
healthcare expenses that they face.
So major cultural
impact on societies.
Clearly this undermines any confidence
sense that our society is protecting one
it, um, there's a demographic impact.
We've already seen the way in which HIV
AIDS is altering the age structure of
whole populations.
And transforming life expectancy and
there's even the possibility of failed
states as a direct result of disease
with enormous implications for security,
political stability and democracy.
But this last fact paradoxically
has also opened a ray of hope.
The realization that I last mentioned
affected the national security
estimate of our own government,
which recommend that in fact HIV AIDS
was a major threat to the security of the
United States the first time that
disease was recognized by the CIA and the
security community as a
threat to our country.
And this was reinforced by studies by,
for example,
the Rand Corporation and the result of
this realization that we are indeed a
global community and that what's happening
in southern Africa and other places
is of enormous impact
throughout the world.
Led to Uracil Ras of investment of funds.
And I'd most like to mention Pepfar,
the president's emergency plan for AIDS
relief that was established by President
Bush in 2004 it now target's 15 countries
has been extended under President
Obama.
And those countries are primarily though
not exclusively and southern Africa.
And it's initially it was $15
billion over several years.
And has been renewed since and it became
the largest commitment of funding to an
international health effort ever recorded.
So this is lead with them.
There's also funds through
the gates foundation,
particularly directed at research
and through the Global Fund for HIV,
AIDS, malaria, and tuberculosis.
One of the conclusions
is that there's been,
that we could reach is that in the last
years under this massive new investment
of effort and funding that the world
health community is developing much more
sophisticated strategies for
dealing with this epidemiology,
that it has much more data and information
and that it's learned a number of
important indeed vital lessons.
What are some of the conclusions that
provide us with them at least a measure of
hope?
One of them is that in
campaigns against this disease,
one size definitely does not fit all.
And here we see another theme of our
course that information hard data is
absolutely crucial to any
effective public health strategy.
Public health needs to be based
on a solid basis of information.
And in this case we see a rapid upscaling
of testing and surveillance as one of
the key components of the global effort
to combat the disease that's necessary
because it establishes the clear idea
that the epidemiology of this disease and
each society is distinctive and that in
turn enables the campaign to concentrate
resources to change tactics depending on
the actual results of the interventions
so far.
So you need to be able to meet in
order to have sound public health
scientifically to assess what you've done
today and to change course if it's not
working properly.
So in one of the hopeful signs in the age,
Penn Dem aids pandemic is that the
campaign is become more sophisticated and
focused and has been realized
that strategies that fit
one phase in the history
of the epidemic may not be
effective at another stage.
And so the response has continually
to be updated and adapted.
The priority now is to clearly identify
high burden areas as a priority and to
saturate them with prevention efforts.
The slogan of Pepfar for this
reason is know your epidemic.
In the past,
for example,
anti AIDS programs failed to target
married couples and in people in longterm
relationships,
couples in which one part particular
partner in particular is HIV positive,
while the other is not in the jargon of
the World Health Organization discordant
couples.
Another lesson that the
commitment cannot be short term,
that it must be sustained.
That short term interventions that are
then scaled back can be useless and
counterproductive.
A good illustration is Uganda,
which a few years ago was one of the
bright spots in Africa when the government
invested heavily in sex education,
in the provision of condoms and the
fostering of new and healthy sexual
behaviors.
The results were highly successful until
funding was scaled back and favor of
other priorities and since then the
epidemic and Uganda has resurged with a
vengeance and one could say
something similar about Thailand.
There are also new strategies.
Let me give you a couple of examples.
One is the need to abolish the distinction
in this pandemic between prevention
and treatment as a false dichotomy because
treatment with antiretroviral therapy
is in fact a valid and essential
preventive strategy in particular,
antiretroviral therapy radically lowers
the incidents of vertical transmission
from mother to child.
It's also true that
antiretroviral treatment lowers
the viral load and therefore
reduces transmission.
Antiretroviral therapy is a prophylactic
because it prolongs the life of parents
thereby decreasing the number of
orphans and vulnerable children,
the very people who fuel the sex industry
and are most likely to indulge and
unsafe sex practices because they
locked education resources and access to
medical care.
So pepfar has concentrated recently on
making generic antiretroviral therapies
available and focused countries at an
affordable price and the FDA in this
country has established fast track
approval to allow antiretrovirals to be
rapidly reviewed and cleared.
By the end of 2008 antiretroviral therapy
had been extended to 10 million people
with HIV AIDS and especially to
pregnant women who are HIV positive.
Another hopeful sign.
At first,
pepfar was ideologically motivated and
stipulated that one third of its funding
had to go to abstinence only education,
but this has been demonstrated by to be
counter productive and so has largely
been dropped and funding has been direct,
redirected towards other
aspects of the program.
Another stress has been on
gender inequality and here
I want to stress that it's
not only poverty but in a quality
that drives this epidemic forward.
Let me give you the example of Swazi lend,
which is at the epicenter
of this pandemic.
One third of women in the 18 to 24 age
group were found to have experienced
sexual violence as had one quarter of
girls under 15 so providing education and
reeducation,
stressing the dangers of power
differentials and intimate
relationships has been
important in demonstrating the devastating
consequences of sexual entitlement
and also offering adolescent
women vocational training
so that they would have
the skills necessary in the marketplace
and hence the economic independence.
That was a major determinant of
public health until recent years.
HIV AIDS programs avoided what might
be called social economic and cultural
determinants of the pandemic.
Concentrating on generic awareness but
not confronting the specifics of local
situations that fueled the epidemic.
Let me give you an example of targeting
specific high burden groups and areas.
One of them has been in recent years the
targeting of intravenous drug users and
removing ideological blinkers and simply
talking in terms of epidemiology and
hard science leading to such innovations
as needle exchange programs to make
blood safe and indeed in a
couple of countries to opioid
substitution treatments
to remove or at least to downscale heroin
addiction thereby once again lowering
the rates of transmission.
Another major intervention has been
on establishing safe blood supplies,
combating what we might call the medical
transmission of HIV AIDS through the
establishment of laboratories when with
them the screening of all blood and the
recruitment of donors from low risk
sectors of the population on a non
remunerated basis or there's been
the awareness of the utility of male
circumcision as a prophylaxis
dick measure in this app pandemic.
Let me then just contrast the situation
in sub Saharan Africa where the epidemic
is in the population,
the general population with a couple of
other worrying places in the world and
I'll, and then on a slightly
more somber note, um,
some places that are currently
sources of concern outside of Africa.
There's eastern Europe and the former
areas of the Soviet Union where Unh has
talked about an emerging epidemic.
Unlike that of southern Africa.
The epidemic is a d has
a different profile.
It's a concentrated epidemic showing
prevalence among high risk groups like
intravenous drug users
in Saint Petersburg,
30% of intravenous drug users are under
19 years of age and the sharing of
needles is the norm and it's also driven
by the sex industry and by the collapse
of the healthcare system and fueled also
by some religious attitudes which scorn
sex education and the use of condoms
or devote resources to a practice of
abstinence education which
has drawn monster bubbly,
not worked or there's East Asia and the
Pacific again and directing drug use,
sex industry,
low condom use and sexual tourism.
All of these risk factors
that are cumulative.
And I'll conclude just with a couple of
worrying points about our own country.
The outbreak began in the
80s as far as we know,
peaked around 1993 and then declined
steeply until proximately the year 2001
since which time there's been an
upturn and a surprising degree of
misinformation has abounded
new infections.
We can see demonstrate that
the epidemic has transformed,
been transformed unlike, and the, uh,
the epidemic in the United
States is totally unlike
what's happening in southern
Africa. New Infections are
overwhelmingly among men,
718,000 males affected and 160,000 women.
And it tends to be among
concentrated groups,
men who have sex with men, drug
users, and ethnic minorities,
African Americans who have half of
the new cases in the last few years.
And Hispanics,
a transformation occurred.
AIDS in the 1980s was primarily a
disease among the white population.
It has since declined among whites and
spread disturbingly among minorities,
African Americans,
Hispanics and Asians.
So at that point,
I'll refer you to Wednesday when we'll
talk about the United States in greater
detail.
And I just conclude since I've run out
of time by saying at the pandemic at the
moment is extremely active.
The most hopeful thing I could say to
you is not that it's being controlled,
but that it seems to
be globally stabilized,
but there are a number of really worrying
places in the world and some very
worrying developments.